Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
So in the previous
couple of
gatherings
we discussed
the timings of prayer. We discussed the
starting time, the ending time of each
prayer, the ideal time, the bare minimum
time.
Now we have to discuss an issue that
will
be rather new to many
of us I believe and
that is an issue regarding
making salah outside of his prescribed
time.
We've discussed the start and end time
of each prayer. And we've discussed the
excuses a person may have to join
prayers and there will be an entire book
dedicated to that which is joining
prayers and the excuses for that and so
forth.
But this here is discussing
a person having no legitimate excuse.
When we say legitimate excuse,
we are speaking about an excuse from
Allah, from the messenger of Allah.
This is a legitimate excuse.
Human beings have excuses for
everything. If you see one man kill
another, he'll have an excuse why he
killed him, right?
But not all excuses are valid. The only
excuse that is considered valid is the
excuse that comes from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala or his messengeratam.
And so
this is the
what the author is going to discuss now.
And I want to make sure that we
understand this in the spirit in which
the author intends it. And that is that
a person
knowingly,
purposely
makes a prayer outside of its ordained
time
without a legitimate excuse.
That is what we're discussing here.
Making a salah out of its prescribed
time
knowingly,
purposely
without a legitimate excuse. Legitimate
excuse means what?
What is a legitimate excuse?
[Arabic recitation]
sallallah.aii wasallam. Person says I
was working. Person says I was sleeping.
Person says I was gaming. Person says I
was shopping. These are all excuses.
Right? But the only excuses which are
valid are the excuses which come from
Allah. The one who obligated and set
these parameters to start with. He is
the only one who has the right to change
or break these rules that he sets.
Subhanahu wa'ta'ala. And so
the following is an excerpt of
from his book mu
and it is discussing that exact point
that I just mentioned and that is a
person makes salah outside of its
prescribed time knowingly purposely
without a legitimate excuse.
He says,
Abdul walked in.
Wasam.
[Silence]
So essentially this is the point that he
makes. I want you to imagine something
with me. Imagine a person knows that
starts at when is now 506. Okay.
person says, "Well, I'm going to be busy
at 5:06, so I'm going to go ahead and
make sal at 4:45.
I'm going to make at 4:30, not 506. I'm
going to make salah at 4:00 because I'm
planning to be busy at 5:06." What would
we say
with respect to this prayer? Valid or
invalid?
Invalid. Everybody agrees with that,
right? So what is the difference between
that person and the person who says I'm
busy now I'm going to make salah at 7:06
not at 506. What is the difference
between those two? One prayed it before
its start time. One prayed it after its
end time.
Is there a difference between the two?
Let's say a person
other acts of worship have to start in
end times Ramadan. Person says well
I'm going to be busy during Ramadan.
It's inconvenient. Therefore I will fast
Ramadan this year during Shabban.
We would all agree that this is what
invalid. Correct. A person says I'm busy
right now. I will fast Ramadan inshaw
without an excuse to break his fast.
What is the difference between those
two? Inherently,
there is no difference
between praying before its time and
after its time. The only difference is
the excuse. Does a person have a
legitimate allowance from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala?
And so something fud fud has no
time allowance for a traveler, for
someone who's sick, for someone who's in
war. Fud has to be made at a very
particular time. And so there is no
legitimate excuse for a person to pray
fud after its set time.
Just there is no excuse to make
fudg before it's set time for a person
who is conscious a person who does it
purposely
there is no permissibility for this.
Likewise when we look at the remainder
of the four prayers we have two times
two general times daytime and nighttime.
Daytime is and nighttime is
when a person has an excuse to join
prayers those two times become one long
time. So a person who has an excuse to
join and the time for the daytime prayer
for that person begins at the be
beginning of and ends with the sun
setting and likewise for the nighttime.
If a person knowingly takes a daytime
prayer and makes it at night or vice
versa, this is an invalid prayer. It
doesn't matter how many times a person
makes it up. Just the person who
broke or did not fast Ramadan during
its time or fasted the Ramadan before
its time or a person who prayed before
his time, it is impossible to make that
prayer up. Why? because it has a start
and end time. If it only had a starting
time,
then we could make it up zaka.
Let's say a person fails to give zaka
for a number of years and they wish to
repent for this. What do they do? They
pay zaka for all of the years that they
missed. Even if it's 50, even if it's a
hundred years. Why? Because zak has a
start time but it does not have a what?
An expiration time. However, for
something salah that has a start
and end time if a person does not have a
legitimate excuse that salah cannot be
made up. What does the person is the
person obligated to do? The person is
obligated to repent for this. This is a
major sin and this is a consensus
amongst the scholars of Islam and the
jurists and that is that knowingly
without a valid legislative excuse
taking salah out of its prescribed time
and making it during a time that is past
its expiration or before there is no
difference. The person is considered to
have not made salah because time is one
of the conditions of salah. Correct?
So what else is a condition of salah?
wudoo correct
you know but for for simplicity's
sake is a condition of salah. A person
knowingly makes salah without wudoo
without an excuse. What would we say
with respect to this salah?
Not only is it invalid, but it's never
happened. I mean, legislatively, it
never happened. Physically, it happened,
right? But legislatively,
the person didn't pray. The man that was
making salah and it was in in the
masid in Bkari. He was making salah come
up afterwards and says to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and his
response would be
go back and pray. You have not prayed
yet.
Physically he prayed but legislatively
he did not pray. This is not prayer.
Making salah without is not this is not.
He did not pray making outside of its
time. making during time making after.
This is not correct. This is not.
So a person either has an excuse or
doesn't. And we're going to get into the
excuses for joining the prayers.
However, in general, if a person
knowingly takes the time of prayer out
of its prescribed time and especially
daytime into night and nighttime into
day, this person is obligated to repent.
As for making up the it's not possible
and this actually is
a bit of a mercy because if someone
comes and says I haven't prayed for 10
years what do we say make salah for 10
years past
not possible this person is still
repentant and start praying
[Arabic recitation]